hi this is International master David
proofs for chess con and today we're
going to do the second part of a very
very fundamental area of end games which
is the King and single pawn against King
so I have another fundamental position
for you right here which is the king is
in front of his own pawn and he's on the
sixth rank the enemy King is on the
eighth rank in the way of the pawn and
so successfully blocking and defending
this territory here now it turns out
that this position is a win for white if
it's White's move or if it's blacks move
but it's very important for you to learn
and remember why that is so first we're
going to look at it with black to move
because that's the easiest the black
King will be forced to step aside here
if he has to move right because he and
the white King are each controlling
three squares in front of each other and
since black has to move that means white
has the opposition the black King steps
out of the way the white King moves
forward and you can see the white king
controls all three steps and the pawn
will Queen very very simple so now let
us pretend that it is White's move
instead if it's White's move here when
the white King is going to have to step
out of the way right so the white King
has to step aside and the black King is
definitely going to want to stand in
front of him and block him right he's
not going to want to run away and let
the White King forward so the black King
has to step in front of him and block
him but if you counted out and you
remember the position with the pawn on
the seventh rank that I showed you last
time you'll see that in this one
position white can win by just advancing
his pawn in front of his own King the
black King has to go in front of the
pawn the pawn goes here taking away two
more squares from the King and it
happens to be black smooth black steps
out of the way the white King comes
forward and he Queens so in summary in
this position white always wins you
should know this position is very very
important now let's talk about one or
two of their observations about King and
pawn endings
all right rook pawns in rook pawns
what's special about them is it doesn't
matter if your King is on the sixth it
doesn't matter who has the opposition
the only thing that matters is if the
black King can get there in time to stop
the pawn from queening without any aid
from the king okay so here we can see
that the black King can catch this pawn
in time right okay so now let's say we
bring the white King up here and we let
the white king have the opposition here
they go and now the black King has to
step aside but the white King is not
able to walk around the black King
because there's no file
I know file to the right so the King
can't flank the black King he has to
just step back here and the black in
just steps back here and in fact the
black King can move back to the
eighth-ranked and it doesn't matter
white can never ever get control of H a
and if white starts to move this pawn
down the board
in a situation like this the black king
has nowhere to step out of the way to
let your king forward and queen and so
he's stalemated so those are the reasons
why with a rook pawn
it's basically always a draw okay so
that is fundamental to King and pawn end
games to know that those rook pawns are
almost always draws now let's go over
the last important thing that we need to
know and the last thing that you need to
know is the drawing technique in a
situation where your king is somewhere
blocking the pond from queening and the
king is not already on the sixth rank
with the pawn behind him okay so in this
situation it's White's move black has
the opposition so the white King can
only move it back and forth or allow the
pawn to step in front of him once the
pawn steps past the king now white seems
to have the opposition because the black
King has to step aside but the black
king can move here and the white King
can't move to the corresponding square
because the pawns in the way so the
white King actually won't be able to
walk around the black King because black
comes forward like this so the white
King could drop back now in this
situation is black you always want to
drop straight back instead of dropping
back diagonally it's just good policy to
go to the square where your opponent's
King can't go to the corresponding
Square and take the opposition from you
and when he comes up you can always take
the opposition from him it's blocking
him so eventually if white wants to make
progress he'll have to push the pawn
forward more and check you right his
King can maneuver around behind the pawn
all at once your King will always be
able to keep up so eventually he's going
to play this check you'll move here
he'll move here to defend the pawn now
which way should you fall back which are
these three choices straight back okay
always straight back because if the
white King comes forward you want to
block him the white King comes back here
you come forward again he comes here
which way should you go
drop straight back right forward when
you can to this square here otherwise
straight back and whenever he comes
forward you block him
finally he checks you you stay in front
you go back he comes to the side now
here at the very last rank is when it's
most important not to mess up if you
ever step here and let your opponent
play this move you will lose you have to
step aside he comes here remember this
important 7th rank position with these
pieces your King has to step out of the
way and the opponent Queens so this is
where you need to be really careful
don't step on this square or this square
unnecessarily keep going between these
squares as long as you can okay and only
when you can't go to this square then
you block your opponent's king when he
comes here and you force him back back
back now where should I go here that's
right and here and block and finally he
will check you your king will come here
and get a draw by stalemate now you may
want to quickly run through that endgame
again either playing against yourself or
by replaying this video and before I
make any of the moves for black in this
last example before I make each of those
boos for black try and imagine in your
head the correct move very very quickly
okay so it's an instantaneous response
for you and that is how you can usually
draw the King and pawn versus King
endgame if if your opponent doesn't have
his King in front of the pawn and have
controlled the opposition I hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll see you
around on chess comm I hope you enjoyed
this video and I'll see you around on
chess calm